england of one and are into their first
major tournament final since 1966
and they've deserved it no question
they've deserved it they've played
better in some of the other games
but you hold your nerve you win matches
you do whatever you could it's what alf
ramsay did in
in 1966 he had his critics he had his
own style of play
he says i'm here to win the world cup i
don't care what you think about my style
and gareth southgate's taking some slack
as well but he said i'm here to win
matches
i know what i'm doing he's kept them
calm the team are enjoying themselves
they've stayed calm
we're not gone they've done it we've
we've been
on the edge of our seats up and down
like yeah yes but uh they know what
they're doing
and they're into the final they've done
it so i mean everybody's been saying you
know is
football coming home now they've done
this do you do you think that that
sunday's in the bag
it's absolutely not in the bag it's
really a step above
denmark not in terms of the world
rankings only slightly denmark will rank
10 in the world england for
italy between the two there's not a lot
in it italy been fantastic this
tournament they are a
much bigger threat going forward than
denmark their midfielder really strong
i think england can score goals against
if they've been strong in italy
uh i think there'll be goals at either
end i think it'll be exciting
come on it's it's in the start if it
wasn't gonna be if it wasn't gonna be
denmark's tournament after all that
happened the way they bounced back from
what happened to
christian eriksen on the opening weekend
if it wasn't going to be denmark with
the world behind them
maybe the momentum is with england
you